في تقرير الصادر عن برنامج الامم المتحده
الانماء امس فارض نفسه اليوم كعنواننا
الاول خاصه وانه بيناقش واحده من القضايا
اللي بنعتبرها من قضيان الاساسيه في
تفاعلكم حقيقه التقرير مخيب للاعمال جدا
التقرير بناقش مؤشر التمييز بين الجنسين
في العالم ونتائجه بتقول ببساطه انه
التمييز بين الجنسين ما شاف اي تحسن
اطلاقا في اخر عشر سنوات يعني شيء فعليا
مخيب للاعمال فوق الوصف وطبعا هذه النتيجه
بتعيق تحقيق احد اهداف الامم المتحده
واللي هو تحقيق المساواه بين الجنسين
بحلول عشرين ثلاثين ما في امل يعني لكن
يبدو انه العالم طبعا بعيد سنين ضوئيه زي
ما قلنا عن هذا الهدف البحث شمل 80 دوله
ونتائج وملت 33 صفحه وهذه ببساطه النتائج
باختصار
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده كانت تحلم يختفي التمييز
بين الجنسين خلال سبع سنين والتقرير بيقول
محتاجين 300 سنه التقرير صادم حقيقه ولو
حنختصر ابرز ما فيه في التقرير بيقول انه
تسعه من بين كل عشره في العالم بيميزوا ضد
المراه وهنا بنتكلم على رجال ونساء يعني
تسعه رجال ونساء من بين كل عشره اشخاص في
العالم بميزوا ضد المراه التقرير بيقول
كمان انه نص سكان العالم شايفين الرجال
افضل في القياده السياسيه و43% شايفين
الرجال افضل في اداره الاعمال 46% كمان
شايفين انه الرجل لازم يكون له حقوق اكثر
من السيدات التقرير كمان قال انه زمان كان
دخل الشخص ومستويات تعليمي بيفرق في
النظره للتمييز بين الرجل والمراه لكن
الان المعادي يفرق يعني التحصيل العلمي
العالي او الدخل المرتفع مو بالضروره
معناه مو بالضروري معناه انه الشخص يكون
داعم للمساواه او عدم التمييز الامم
المتحده قالت كمان عكس مكان متوقع حملات
عالميه مثل
اللي بتدافع عن المراه وبتنادي بحقوقها
ووقف الاعتداءات عليها ما اثرت في النظره
العامه للتمييز بين الجنسين ونلا زالت
الاعراف والعادات اقوى من كل شيء في هذا
الخصوص نجي للكلام عن العنف وهنا كارثه
اكبر واكبر في الارقام لانه تقرير اليو ان
دي بي بيقول انه واحد من كل اربعه في
العالم شايفين انه عادي الرجل يضرب زوجته
او شريكته ولو حنتكلم عن الفجوه في الاجور
فمتوسط الفرق 39% يعني الرجال لما بيشتغل
شغلانه والست بتسوي نفس الشغلانه بالضبط
هو بياخد راتب اعلى منها ب 39% مع انه في
57 دوله من الثمانين الستات اكثر تحصيل في
الدرجات العلميه ومع انها كمان خلينا نذكر
بتقضي سته اضعاف الرجل في اداء مهام
الرعايه والمنزل الى جانب وظيفتهم او
عملهم طيب من عمان بيت انضم الينا دكتوره
عصمت حوسو رئيسه مركز الجندر للاستشارات
الاجتماعيه يعني دكتوره عصمت هذا واقع نحن
كلنا عايشينه يعني خلينا نكون صريحين مع
بعض بس لما ينحط في تقرير امامنا ونشوف
الارقام كده كلها مع بعض ونشوف انه يعني
النفق مظلم خلينا نقول صراحه حنشعر
بالاكتئاب خصوصا لما نلاقي انه يعني حتى
النساء بطالعوا او عندهم تمييز ضد المراه
نفس الرجل كيف نقدر نفسر هذا الشيء
اه يعطيك العافيه ساره دايما مواضيعك مهمه
انا بالنسبه الي التقرير مش صادم كوحده
مختصه بعمل بالمجال اطلاقا ما كانت
النتائج صادمه كتير في اسباب راح اسلط
الضوء على اهمها اذا بتاملوا كل المؤسسات
الدوليه والامم المتحده العاملين بهذا
المجال يعملوا تغيير حتى لو بعد كمان
عشرين ثلاثين سنه وبالاضافه للي راح ما
راح يصير تغيير ليش اولا هم بحكوا بلغه
النوع الاجتماعي اللي هو الجندر
والنوع الاجتماعي يعنى في الجنسين يعني هو
بحكي عن المراه والرجل ادوارهم وبيركزوا
على المراه اكثر
فهذا الحكي مؤذي لانه لما يحكوا بلغه
احاديه بس على المراه عامل الموضوع رد فعل
عكسي عند اغلب المجتمعات سواء الغربيه او
دول العالم الثالث والعربيه رد فعل عكسي
وكانه صار الموضوع هجوم شخصي على الرجل
لما نتعامل وا كده لانه هي المراه اللي
بتعاني من المشكله نعم المراه تعاني اكثر
لكن منقدرش نعمن وعلى فكره انا مبسوطه انه
اعتبروا الدراسه عالميه وعلى 85% من سكان
العالم لانه التمييز عندهم وعنا بس
تركيز على دول الناميه بالذات العربيه
وهلكونا بهاي القصه تمييز موجود بكل
العالم تمام لكن الفكره اذا بدكم تحكوا
بلغه الجندري النوع الاجتماعي لازم نحكي
بلغه انسان مراه ورجل ونركز على المتضرر
اكثر لكن ما بنقدر نضلنا نركز على المراه
ونعمل ردود فعل عكسيه عند الرجل هاي سبب
سبب ثاني انهم هم استخدموا نفس الاساليب
نفس الطرق نفس المفاهيم اللي بتناسب
مجتمعاتهم ما عملوا اعتبار نعمل
مفاهيم او اساليب او ادوات تناسب
المجتمعات اللي بنشتغل عليها نحكي بلغتهم
عشان هيك صار في رفض مجتمعي لكل حدا
بيشتغل بحقوق المراه او الجندر لانه هاي
ما غيروها نفس الطريقه ونفس الاسلوب الاهم
من هذا الحكي كله انه
مستحيل نطالب بمساواه بين الجنسين لانه في
فروق بيولوجيه بينهم في فروق سايكولوجيه
في فروق سيولوجيه اذا طالبنا بالمساواه
بينهم نظلمهم الاثنين مع بعض احنا لازم
نطالب
ايه هو هذا يعني هذا موضوع الانسر حيصير
عليه كثير جدل لما الموضوع المساواه
والمساواه في ملف اخر احنا بنتكلم عن
التمييز العداله زي ما ذكرتي حضرتك ايوه
استاذي ساره تحقق المساواه بطريقه غير
مباشره لما نعمل اعتبار انه في فروق فرديه
بينهم وفي فروق
بشكل عام يعني احنا اصلا انا دائما اقول
احنا ما بندور على المساواه احنا احسن
اصلا في كل الاحوال بس انه
المساواه واللي خلق المشاكل والرفض معاناه
المراه اكثر من ما كانت تعاني اوكي
نتائج عكسيه واضح زي هذه الفكره حقتك بس
لما نقول كمان طيب انه زمان كان يقال انه
مثلا كل من الانسان زاد تعليمه او مثلا
بيئته الاجتماعيه او دخلوا او كذا بيصير
متعود على فكره انه المراه لها حقوق وما
الى ذلك لما يقول لك انه موضوع التمييز
حتى ما بتفرق فيه للطبقه ولا ولا شيء يعني
هذا
بيدل على تراجع كبير مصيبه يعني
لانه انا دايما بنادي انه ندخل مفهوم
الجندر على الدماغ نعالج الارث الثقافي في
تقبل الاختلاف وتقبل الاخر واننا نتعامل
مع بعض ونتطور مش بس حضاريا وشكليا وعلميا
لازم نتطور فكريا هذا هذا مفهوم الجندر
لازم يعالج الفكر الانساني اولا الجنسين
هذا اللي بيحقق عدالي وتقبل هلا تقبل
المراه في بعض المواقع للجيل الحالي صار
افضل واريح لكن لسه الارث الثقافي حاملينه
معهم فراح يضلهم يتعاملوا بلغه تمييزيه او
بلغه اعلى سوبر يعني دينيه مع بعض تمام
فاما الجيل اللي سابق قبل ثلاث اربع اجيال
كان مش معتاد فكان مستهجم لكن احنا نتغير
ونشوف المراه بكل المواقع لكن نفس الفكر
بنحمله فبنصدها على مستوى
بقول التمكين تمكين الانسان
للجنسين يبدا من العقل بالاول لازم نغربل
هون ولازم نشتغل بلغه ثنائيه لا يمكن نحصل
على عداله حقيقيه وحقوق للمراه بمعزل عن
العمل مع الرجل لازم نشتغل عليهم الاثنين
هو يعني
صح هو كمان التقرير بياكد على هذا الشيء
انه موضوع الاعراف لا زال هو
المهيمن يعني نحن بنشكرك على هذه
التوضيحات كانت معنا من عمان دكتوره عصمت
رئيسه مركز الجندر للاستشارات الاجتماعيه